[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
June 5th I'm J.R Wellen for the Wall
Street Journal
late August is going to get here faster
than you think that's when federal
student loan borrowers are likely to
have to dig deeper into their finances
to resume making payments wsj personal
finance reporter Julia Carpenter joins
us today so Julia the pause on student
loan repayments has been extended
several times since 2020. what are the
chances it could be extended again it's
very understandable that people have
that confusion especially since we have
had the pause extended so many times
since it was first instituted in March
2020 but as a provision in the debt
ceiling deal we know that student loan
payments and interest accrual will
restart in August so there's pretty much
virtually no chance it'll be extended
again now how is that different from
President Biden's debt forgiveness plan
that's being considered by the Supreme
Court and what's the latest on that so
people probably saw the headlines when
the plan was first announced and we know
that it provides up to ten thousand
dollars for qualified borrowers who make
125 000 a year and up to twenty thousand
dollars for people in that same bucket
who qualified for a Pell Grant so it's a
lot of money on the table people were
very supportive of this this was
something the president had promised but
the court is Weighing on the
constitutionality of this and we're
expected to hear their decision later
this month so whatever the Court decides
yes the plan can go forward or no it
won't we then have a two-month DeLay So
if the plan goes forward people won't
just immediately log into their accounts
and see their debt wiped out overnight
if the plan doesn't go forward I mean we
then have a different scenario either
way though whatever remaining debt you
have whether you know forgiveness moves
on or not that August 30th deadline is
pretty firm now that's when the payments
start again I would imagine many federal
student loan borrowers are holding out
hope the court rules in favor of the
Forgiveness plan understandably
financial advisors are saying no though
if you are holding for that hope you are
not preparing for the other outcome and
then you're in for a shock once this
decision comes I was speaking with
financial advisors who were saying you
should plan for the scenario in which
payments do resume and forgiveness does
not happen in that case you're prepared
it's not going to be this huge blow to
your budget for some people turning
these payments back on after three years
could be a shock to their personal
finances so let's talk about ways to
prepare for some people it's probably
been a while since they went over the
terms of their loan I was speaking with
Scott Buchanan he's the executive
director of the student loan servicing
Alliance so he has talked to a lot of
people about what this is going to mean
for the system specifically what this is
going to mean for borrowers trying to
contact their servicers so his
recommendation was called your loan
servicer Now call them go over the terms
of your loan go over your monthly
payment go over you know am I in the
right payment plan are there changes I
can be embracing all these different
things because come August as soon as
we're creeping up on that August 30th
deadline for payment resumption Mill
millions of other borrowers are going to
be calling and we're going to be
clogging the phone lines so his
recommendation calls sooner rather than
later okay but people's finances are
getting squeezed a lot more today due to
inflation than they were the last time
they were making payments what kind of
adjustments should they consider making
in their household budgets I've spoken
with a lot of borrowers who say you know
originally they were setting aside that
money they were thinking okay I'll put
it in savings or I'll put it towards
something else so that when payments
resume I'm ready and then inflation has
just been growing around all of your
budgets eating up more and more so
inflation ran up to near 10 and even
though inflation has now come down
prices are still rising and people have
baked this into a lot of their budgets
you know three years is a really really
long time so as we heard last week on
your show Jr many people took on bigger
spending habits during the pandemic so I
was speaking with financial advisors
they say the best thing to do right now
is to try and get a very firm
understanding of your cash flow look at
your budget now look at what your
monthly payment would need to be for
your student loan and ahead of August
30th start making some of those hard
decisions you know where can I make
sacrifices where can I cut back where am
I saving money where am I spending too
much money where can you make room so
that your budget can reabsorb that
payment are there other repayment plans
people could consider a lot of people
have probably seen that in January the
Biden Administration announced changes
to income-driven repayment plans these
changes are designed to lower monthly
payments for borrowers and also speed up
your repayment process so income driven
repayment plans are plans that allow you
to pay different monthly payments based
on your income and your family size so
this new plan the revised pay as you
earn plan allows borrowers to pay five
percent of their discretionary income
toward undergraduate loans and after 10
years of payments it wipes out remaining
debt for borrowers with balances less
than twelve thousand dollars so if you
apply for this plan if you are
interested in this plan you should
contact your servicer make sure that you
qualify there's also a loan simulator
tool in the education department website
usually helpful for people to input
their existing information you know your
income your family size your existing
debt and then that calculates what plan
is right for you what your potential
monthly loan payments would be under
there so from there people can see what
their repayment options are what their
other plan options are and determine
whether or not IDR is right for them
that's Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Julia Carpenter and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
foreign